depuis le 15 novembre les autoroutes
ivelinoises sont sous haute surveillance
les plaques de verglas et les chutes de
neige sont scrutées par les agents de
Vincy autoroute ce mur d'image ce mur
d'écran nous permet de voir en temps
réel la circulation les conditions de
circulation si on comme on peut le voir
ici on est plutôt sur une colorométrie
verte c'est-à-dire qu'on a pas
d'événement pas pas de perturbation si
besoin des agents de terrain
interviennent pour prévenir de mauvaises
conditions météorologiques sur toutes
les autoroutes qui traverse les ivelines
c'est-à-dire la 12 la 13 la 14 la 86 la
10 et la 11 avant l'événement on va
préparer la chaussée c'est-à-dire qu'on
va saler la chaussée sur 100 % de sa
surface pour que quand l'épisode
hivernal va
arriver la la chaussée soit traitée et
donc que la glace fonde au même moment
qu'elle apparaît et puis une fois que la
neige tombe et ben il va falloir de
manière assez bête mais pousser la neige
avec nos camions qu'on équipe de lames
les lames vous les avez ici derrière moi
et qui vont permettre de pousser la
neige et de rendre la la chaussée ce
qu'on appelle la chaussée au noir elle
est blanche quand il y a de la neige et
quand on pousse la neige elle devient
noire sur le site de pront evrar 40
salariés travaillent pour assurer les
meilleures conditions pour la route ils
observent en permanence les informations
diffusées par météoance afin d'anticiper
et transmettre les données entre les
agents mais aussi à la radio et sur X
anciennement Twitter on peut donner
quelques conseils à nos à nos clients à
nos usagers de de l'autoroute c'est
renseignez-vous anticipez vos départs
surtout en période hivernale
renseignez-vous des conditions de trafic
des conditions de météo et de tout
autres phénomènees qui peuvent entourer
entourer votre trajet et surtout ne
jamais dépasser les agents présents sur
les routes pendant cette période à
risque le dispositif est mis en place
jusqu'au 15 mars prochain